السودان لم يتحول فقط الى حلبه صراع
للاطراف المتناحره بل بات ايضا سجنا كبيرا
لاخرين باحثين عن النجاه فبالموازاه مع
المساعي لتطبيق وقف اطلاق النار تبذل
الكثير من الدول الكبرى جهودا جباره من
اجل ايجاد حل لاجلاء رعاياها لكن كيف
السبيل الى ذلك عمليه الاجلاء تصطدم
بالعديد من العراقيل اهمها توقف العمل في
الكثير من المطارات الحيويه في البلاد من
بينها مطار الخرطوم وبالتالي فان عمليه
الاجلاء الجوي تبقى معقده للغايه حيث تمر
عبر الاستعانه بمطار اخر والاسم المقترح
مبدئيا هو مطار بورسودان لكن عدم توقف
الاشتباكات يجعل من مغادره الخرطوم عمليه
محفوفه بالمخاطر
الاجلاء البري ايضا يبقى صعبا للغايه في
ظل بعد المسافات بين العاصمه وحدود الدول
المجاوره فضلا على ان الطرقات ليست امنه
بشكل كبير
اجلاء الوفود العالقه في السودان اخذ بعدا
دوليا كبيرا حيث تسابق دول عديده الزمن
لانقاذ رعاياها من جحيم المعارك الاتحاد
الاوروبي بدا فعليا وضع خطط لعمليات اجلاء
المحتمله لرعاياه لكنه اقر ان الظروف
الامنيه غير متوفره للمضي في عمليه كهذه
المشكله ذاتها اعربت عنها الكثير من الدول
كاسبانيا وسويسرا والسويد اما الولايات
المتحده فبادرت الى التحرك لانقاذ رعاياها
من خلال نشر قوات لها في جيبوتي تاهبا لاي
مهمه انقاذ محتمله مهمه تزداد تعقيدا كلما
ازدادت حده المعارك وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات